for our our second talk we have other
problem Prakash will speak about a nice
aspect and some nice progress which
reflects some of the worries of these
algorithms for linear systems and 7fm
programs which is that the the runtime
sounds nice but when you add up all the
requirements can you actually use them
and he'll give us a nice example of how
this can be done okay thank you Adam
so this is joint work with your Dennis
Gaede neither's and and I'll start by
giving some context about linear systems
onwards so so we start with the HDL
algorithm which was the breakthrough
result that that suggested that we could
utilize the intrinsic linear algebra
capabilities of quantum computers to get
exponential speed ups for certain linear
algebra problems so let me quickly
remind you of what the HDL algorithm
does so so first we encode vectors into
quantum states in the following manner
so so the vector X which is an RN is
encoded into the amplitudes of a quantum
state and and this we call the vector
state so the htl algorithm is the
following given a sparse matrix a and
and a back to state B there's a quantum
algorithm to prepare inverse B in time
poly log N and this constitutes an
exponential speed-up because in the
classical setting you would need time
bonyen but but let's let's carefully
look at the assumptions that are going
into this HTT algorithm and the
assumptions are that the state B can be
prepared in poly log in time and that is
poly logins paths so so while it's it's
a fantastic algorithm it's it's giving
you an exponential speed-up but but it's
doing it's performing a task which is
slightly different from what the
classical linear system does so the
classical linear system would return a
vector all the coordinates of the vector
X in RN by the quantum algorithm gives
us a vector state X from which we can
sample
so the htl algorithm has been enormously
influential and led to several proposals
for quantum machine learning algorithms
so I'll just recall some of them work
done by Seth Lloyd and his collaborators
and the group at Microsoft so so we have
proposals for quantum principle
component analysis classification with
l2 SVM's k-means clustering perceptron
nearest neighbors and I'm surely missing
many but again let's look a bit
carefully at what kind of speeds do we
have so so there are always some
assumptions from the data like you want
it to be sparse of n conditioned or some
other assumptions and and this also in
the machine learning community there's
often Elven regularization but in in
quantum computing we can solve l2
problems because we have Hilbert spaces
so there's so there's also this issue
and and we would like to have a Gordon's
which are compatible with the classical
which solve exactly the same problem as
the classical ones too so so arguably to
the best of our knowledge it has been an
open problem to find the quantum machine
learning algorithm with exponential
burski speed ups for for solving a
problem which is directly comparable to
a classical one so in this work the
proposed quantum recommendation systems
as a solution to this problem so let me
comment on the strengths of this work so
so so firstly that G is an exponential
speed-up over classical with similar
assumptions and guarantees secondly it's
an end-to-end application like we
described all the issues of data access
V and and and it works for all kinds of
datasets there are no assumptions on the
data set and and thirdly it solves the
same problem as a classical
recommendation system namely the problem
of giving good recommendations to to
users so so next I am going to describe
the recommendation problem and let's see
what we solve so for the recommendation
problem we have a preference matrix so
it's indexed by users and products so so
the so they are M users which you see on
the so there M users which we see down
here and n products so think of M and n
to be very large
ranging in the millions and and the
system has some information about how
much these users like these products for
example use of one likes product one
with bit point one out here so he
doesn't really like product one so so P
IJ is the ban is value of item J for
user I and and these samples from P
arrive in an online manner when when
users log in to the system and express
their preference for the product so so
this preference matrix is mostly unknown
like there are lots of question marks we
really don't know how much the users
like unknown products we only know what
they have reviewed about so so the task
of the recombination system is to
provide good recommendations for these
users based on the partial information
we have and and this cannot be done in
general but can be done under the
assumption that P has a good ranky
approximation now this assumption is
well justified in the classical
literature so so we can justify it
saying that there are only a few
intrinsic reasons why people prefer
products and also empirically by by
seeing the real world preference
matrices and seeing that they have a
good rank ii approximation for small key
so the task of the recommendation system
is to reconstruct these
entries like a classical recommendation
system would reconstruct these missing
entries and after reconstruction would
be done under this ranking assumption so
so this has been a very important
problem for for many people if if you
need an incentive there's the Netflix
prize which which was to find bits no
more more accurate recommendation
systems and as we can see like even a
small improvement in recommendations
accuracy has significant consequences so
so let's see how do classical algorithms
perform the task of recommendation so
the classical approach recommendation
systems is through matrix reconstruction
algorithms which would reconstruct an
algorithm which would reconstruct a
matrix P tilde which is close to P using
the low rank assumption and would
require time polyamine so so even if I
allow you pre-computation for the
classical system it still requires poly
n to give an online recommendation
because you have to for the particular
user you have to reconstruct his entire
preference vector which has size n and
then choose the entries which have high
value to give the high quality
recommendations so so one could ask the
question of good a quantum algorithm
sample from from the high value
recommendations and thus achieve as an
exponential speed-up so so in this work
we show that this actually can be done
like an H attained like algorithm can
sample from from the from the
reconstructed matrix and and we can
obtain a quantum recommendation
algorithm with the running time poly K
times polynomial which which is an
exponential speed-up over a classical
system which would need time poly n
because it has to reconstruct the entire
vector of preferences
so let me go into some more detail into
the computation model under which we
work so the samples from this preference
matrix arrived in an online manner and
are stored in a data structure with poly
logarithmic update time so so it's it's
the data structure store some additional
metadata and it's it's structured as a
binary tree so the purpose of this data
structure is to allow you to create
vector States efficiently corresponding
to the known rules of the preference
matrix so so importantly I would like to
say that we we use the standard memory
model the the memory model used for
algorithms like global search the Oracle
model and and and we store this data
structure in in the standard model in
like we have Oracle access to this
particularly destruction and and the
user comes into the system in an online
manner and system is able to provide
good recommendations in in time poly K
poly log MN as opposed to a classical
one which would mean time poly mmm
so so the main a technical tool for
recommendation systems is it's a
singular value decomposition so let me
quickly remind you of the single value
decomposition so for a given matrix a we
can write the singular value
decomposition as a being a sum of Sigma
I you I the a transpose where you I and
VI are orthonormal unit vectors and
Sigma I have the positive quantities
known as the singular values so so the
singular value is closely connected to
rank K approximations in the Frobenius
norm so so the rank K approximation ek
is obtained by truncating the singular
value spectrum up to K terms and and it
minimizes a - a KF like it gives you the
best rank K approximation when the error
is measured in the Frobenius norm so so
in this work we we use a quantum analog
of the singular value decomposition so
we call it's quantum singular value
estimation and let me describe what the
quantum analog is so so that is quantum
algorithm with running time poly log
came in a wet salon that transforms a
vector say it like given a vector state
which is a superposition over these
singular vectors and for I VI in current
superposition it's able to estimate
these singular values
it gives us an additive error estimate
of the singular value sigma i bar so
there's an additive error of epsilon
times the Frobenius norm of a and and
it's able to do this with high
probability and and and the running time
depends on is like scales as one of
epsilon so so I'm not going to describe
this algorithm in this talk like the
focus will be on how to construct matrix
sampling based recommendation system so
and use this as a black box
but but this is the main technical tool
that goes into the construction quantum
recommendation system
so so now so now I'm going to describe
how to construct the combination system
that's based on matrix sampling and then
how to implement it using quantum
singular value estimation so so given
the preference matrix we can construct a
binary 0 1 matrix T such that T IJ is
equal to 1 if item J is a good
recommendation for user I so for example
in the matrix we saw earlier we had
highlighted these entries which the
users valued highly and and now these
are set to 1 and the rest are set to 0
so there many ways one could construct
this matrix T out of the preference
matrix for example if it were thumbs-up
thumbs-down setting one would have it
immediately or one could choose the the
items that the users value more than a
threshold or the 10,000 best items for
them and so on so so so from the
preference matrix we construct this
binary this binary 0 1 matrix T which
which also has a low-rank approximation
for reason similar to the classical
recommendation assumptions but as with
the preference matrix we don't really
know the entries of T so what we have
the subsample of the ideal matrix T so
if we set all these question marks to 0
we can say that we have a matrix T hat
which is a subsample of the ideal matrix
team
so so now this light decides the
conceptual structure of the matrix
sampling based recommendation system so
it's it's so let me describe it in more
detail so so we have this preference
matrix P which we round to construct a
binary matrix T which could be done in
different ways but most entries of T are
unknown we don't have access to T
actually what we have is the uniform
subsample of T which we call t hat so t
hat is the matrix on the previous slide
which is obtained by setting all these
question marks to zero and we have some
known information about so so in the
classical recommendation setting we have
a low rank assumption on T so so we know
that the rank key approximation to T is
a good approximation and in particular
if we could sample from TK then we would
have good recommendations but
unfortunately we don't have T so we have
to work with T hat so so the suggested
algorithm is to do a single value
decomposition on T hats to find T hat K
and and we would like to have that
sampling from t hat k also gives us good
recommendations so to complete this
analysis we use the results of a Cleo
Pearson McSherry from from 2001 and we
have to extend them a bit so these
results show us that in fact it suffices
to sample from D hat K and sampling from
T half G actually gives you good
recommendations so so the algorithmic
parts in this figure are in blue like
what we said algorithmic parts first we
round this preference matrix to a binary
matrix then we have the sub sample
matrix and we perform an SVD on it in
the classical setting and and the
quantum analog would be to do a quantum
singular value estimation as I said a
few slides back so there are these
assumptions of low rank so these are
essentially the same assumptions as the
classical months so so the quantum
recommendation system would work if they
would give you guarantees almost similar
to the classical one and there's also a
uniform subsampling assumption that the
the t hat is a uniform subsample of t
and and the main
classical analysis goes through this by
extending this result of a clear
Pleasant machete which says that D hat K
is actually feels to Tk so so that's the
basic structure of the matrix sampling
based recommendation system so let me
quickly remind you again so T is the
binary recommendation matrix obtained by
rounding P D hat is a uniform subsample
which is rescaled so so sorry it should
be a t-they but this is the uniform sub
sampling process we be sampled with
probability P and rescaled so that the
Frobenius norm is the same and TK and TK
hat are the low rank approximations
the classical low rank assumption says
that TK is a good low-rank approximation
to T and then alice' says that sampling
from a matrix close to TK hat is opposed
to TK would give you good
recommendations
so that answers goes through two parts
so the first one is that samples from TK
itself are good recommendations and this
this follows as TK is a binary matrix
and and we can extend this guarantee for
to be averse case one for a large
fraction of the typical users so by a
typical user I mean a user for which we
have information a user who has reviewed
a number of products close to the
average
so samples from TK are good
recommendations for a large fraction of
typical users and and but then we need
to show that sampling from TK hat
surprises and and this is essentially a
result due to a clear obvious and
McSherry which says that if you do a
uniform subsampling with some
probability P then with very high
probability we have a matrix
approximation result so so actually we
need to extend this a bit because what
amalga rhythm has some error
it doesn't sample exactly from t hat k
but from some matrix so it projects not
onto all single values greater than k
then the threshold sigma but also some
in an interval around Sigma so because
of this error we have to extend the
actors maturity to the sitting and we
are able to show that that when the
sample from the t hat sigma k matrix we
still have a good low-rank approximation
and so sampling from this t hat Sigma K
matrix suffices so then alpha says that
for most typical users the samples from
t hat sigma k i would be good
recommendations with high probability
so so now with all this we we can now
state what the quantum algorithm should
be so the quantum algorithm would be to
prepare the state t hat i corresponding
to the state for user i
then to apply the quantum projection
algorithm to the state to obtain this
projected state so we are basically
projecting on to the high similar values
subspace and then to measure this
projected state in the computational
basis to get recommendation so let me
say something about the running time at
this point so so the right so for the
htl algorithm the running time depends
on the condition number so but for the
projection algorithm we are able to do
better because we choose a a threshold
which is which is related to the rank
like this matrix t hat has a good
low-rank approximation so it suffices to
project onto onto a threshold which is
closely related to the rank which is
like 1 by paly rank
so so we are able to avoid this
dependence on the condition number and
and it makes sense because most of the
mass of this matrix is concentrated in
this high rank subspace so so I'll
quickly describe how to do this
projection assuming the single value
decomposition so select a be the
singular value decomposition for a given
matrix and we write the input X in the
singular value basis and now we estimate
these single values to additive error
Kappa Sigma over two so if you so if you
remember from the previous slide this
Kappa Sigma over 2 would need would need
time poly K so having done this singular
value estimation the
the Adhan Oxley register and and project
to to the space of high singular vectors
and then it is Sigma I bar as it's a
unitary and post selector on T equal to
one so the process gives us output which
is a projection onto all the singular
values greater than Sigma and some in
the error interval one minus Kappa Sigma
and Sigma so I'm not going to describe
how to do single value estimation in
this talk so let me conclude with some
open questions so so firstly it suggests
that one could try to build classical
matrix sampling based recommendation
algorithms so so one question is of
course whether this can be done whether
one could construct a polychaete poly
log M in classical recommendation
algorithm and the alternative would be
to prove a lower bound that rules out
the existence of such an algorithm and
and of course one would like to find
more quantum machine learning algorithms
which have guarantee is comparable to
the classical months so so let me
conclude with these open problems thank
you
so we have plenty of time for questions
anyway sure can I first just make sure I
understand what you mean by uniform
subsampling is it that the probability
that you have the you have data on the
users preference is uniform across the
entire matrix like you the chance that
you actually have some data is uniform
so so the system has partial information
about the users so so you're assuming
that the process by which you're getting
this information is a uniform subsample
no I'm just asking to make sure I
understand what uniform subsampling
means right so there's this unknown
matrix T which which expresses su but
you have a sample of this matrix right
because your recommendation system has
partial information when users come into
the system right so the assumption is
that the sampling process is uniform
okay so that doesn't sound like a safe
assumption in most of these kind of
Netflix Amazon kind of situations where
like would you have a better assumption
they could you make a well I mean it
sort of tends to be that you have like
some products that like you have a lot
of data about and then you have this
long tail of things that like nobody's
really reviewed or anything like that so
so what happens to this algorithm if you
have to get rid of that assumption
so the guarantee they would have is for
typical users who have reviewed an
average number of products within some
constant fraction of the average let's
see
so for these users we are able to prove
over skins guarantee and and I believe
the system would work fine but but the
analysis would be much harder okay
that
I would like to ask about the assumption
on on low-rank so well you you basically
have three matrices first you start with
B which has this fractional these
fractional numbers and then you convert
it to zero of a matrix and then you
subsample it so exactly what which of
these matrices should be low rank and
and how does this tool reference matrix
is assumed to be low rank and that's
been known assumption using the
classical literature so so the so the
assumption is on the preference matrix
and the matrix team and and it's valid
for basically the same reasons as you
can assume for the classical one like
there's nothing quantum about it so you
say that basically in it's reasonable to
assume that that it's been assumed that
has to be ante have good low rank
approximations okay thank you yeah and
back Nathan
cheers thanks a lot so one question I
was hoping you can clarify for me about
the input to the algorithm particularly
the preference matrices it looked to me
like you need to use aq Ram like
structure in order to be able to load
that in and that that of course is can
be pronounced potentially problematic
for a lot of these algorithms so could
you talk a little bit more about the
size and the assumptions about depth
versus you know circumcised trade-offs
here okay so so using the standard
Oracle model which would be then Gordon
use which would be the memory model used
for global search and all that the query
algorithms so so the difference is that
we are storing a data structure some
oxalate the information which which can
be computed in a streaming setting but
this update time is poly logarithmic so
so we can rapidly build up the street a
structure and keep it in in memory so if
you believe that global search can be
implemented then I would say this
algorithm can also be implemented that's
it answer your question or I may miss it
so then if I'm understanding this this
suffers from all of the implementations
that you would get our problems you
would get trying to implement Grover's
or a call in an Iraq you in a general
setting right yes so I would say that if
you could implement global search you
could also do this
so then it suffers from all the problems
@qm suffers from she'll I'm great thank
you
and maybe a little question is how much
quantum storage does it need so um so it
needs to store each entry of the
preference matrix that says wanted e
come in so with a log overhead for each
entry of the preference matrix thanks
[Music]
so it seems like the main power from the
main thing that this algorithm is using
his quantum SVD decomposition and I
wonder if there's any other obvious
examples where you can use this yes yeah
that would be an interesting open
question so this quantum SVD comes out
of quantum box and phase estimation and
and it's definitely a interesting open
question to see if it has further
applications
any any other questions okay if not
let's think I don't come again for a
nice talk